hello in this video I would talk about
the M phase sightings and how they
regulate cell cycle progression the key
M phase cycling is cycling B and its
partner cdk1 together cycling B and its
partner cdk1 this complex is known as
maturation promotion promoting factor
and this cycling B and cdk1 is a part of
spindle assembly checkpoint in this
video we would also look at how cycling
B and silica one helps in speed it works
as a spindle assembly checkpoint and
ensures that equal segregation of the
genetic material happens between the
daughter cells now first question we
should ask is when cycling B cdk1
is activated cycling B and silica one is
mostly active during M phase and at the
late g2 phase cycling beads activate
cycling B is activated and coming up now
first of all how cycling B is activated
that's the question
so cycling be in an inactive state has
two type of modification one is the
activator II phosphorylation entry own
in 161 residue and another there are two
inhibitory phosphorylation at three own
in 14 and tyrosine 15 residues now at
the end of g2 and the beginning of the M
phase
there are phosphatases known as CDC 25
phosphatase which can cleave off this
inhibitory phosphorylation from the
cyclin b and cdk1
as a result now the only activated
phosphorylation remains and the compound
that the complex is activated so now
active MPF can serve its function and
can phosphorylate several dams
downstream target and we would look at
that then we should ask that when the
cyclin b is degraded and how cyclin b
silica activity is restricted to the M
phase now once M phase is over that
means the cell is going next g1 phase
then cycling B need to be degrade
otherwise the sale would always try to
do stuff which is necessary for EM phase
so cycling B need to be decorated and it
turns out that cycling B is degraded in
the early g1 phase but how it is
decorated
so there are complexes known as anaphase
promoting complexes which works like a
cubic routine like s so they put
ubiquity in marks on the cycling beam
and as a result the proteasome degrades
the cycling B into pieces and that's why
at and cycling B cdk1 activity is
restricted to the M phase of the cell
cycle only now we should be asking that
what cycling B and cdk1 is important for
what are their jobs one of the most
important job at the M phase is to
condense the chromatin because chromatin
need to be condensed in order to be
packaged in a proper metaphase
chromosome and the condensation can only
start with several condensing proteins
some structural maintenance protein like
condensing cohesin etc can bind to the
chromosomes and the chromosome became
more compact so that is triggered by
phosphorylation by this complex cycling
B and C decay one another important
aspect in the prophase is a nuclear
envelope breakdown nuclear envelope is
broken down when the basic skeleton
which is made up of lamin is
phosphorylated by cyclin b and city k1
as a result the nuclear envelope is
breaking down otherwise fragmentation of
the Gaulke apparatus spindle formation
all these things are also regulated by
cycling B and silicon one activity now
in the prophase the cell condensation is
triggered by cycling B and C D k1 and
also the nuclear lamin breakdown is
triggered by cycling B silica one
phosphorylation and as a result the
nuclear envelope is gone now and the
events of the M phase could be triggered
the most important part that the most
import
roll that cycling Basilica one place is
making sure that the microtubules from
the opposite poles are properly attached
to the kinetochores region of these
metaphase chromosomes if the tension is
not equal on the both side then it
generates an error signal like depicted
here now before we look at how this
error signal is detected we should look
at what happens normally normally when
cell goes from metaphase to anaphase
what happens is there are important
complexes known as separating as their
name suggests they break the cohesin
rings setting the metaphase chromosome
free and the equal tension from the two
side separates the metaphase chromosome
and dynamic instability of the
microtubule pulls the chromosome towards
its Pole but when the tension from the
other either side of the poles are
uneven and the microtubules are not
properly attached to the kinetochore
region of the chromosome then that error
signal is detected by a protein known as
mat 2 which inhibits cyclin B and C to
give one complex and as a result
separate cannot break down the cohesin
rings as if something some internal
signal is telling the cell to stay back
in this M phase and try to correct its
error and then it can again attempt a
division that is how M phase cycling's
are so important in equal segregation of
genetic material into the two daughter
nuclei I hope you enjoyed this video if
you like this video to like share and
subscribe thank you